what are the dirtiest words from the
darkest moments of the economic crisis
for many bank bailout and too big to
fail are right up there the way it went
was taxpayers swallowed multi-billion
euro bank losses but didn't get a whiff
of the profits not any more say meps who
have pushed through a banking union
package a key component of which is
protecting the taxpayer from future bank
collapse
in the last economic crisis we suffer a
lot of the situation today i don't know
which consequence it will have on my
everyday life
but i hope that it will be positive
in political economic press
a solid majority of meps agree passing
the final part of the package which not
only protects eurozone and non-eurozone
taxpayers but also secures deposits of
up to 100 000 euros and establishes
independent early warning and crisis
management through the european central
bank banks shareholders and creditors
would be the first to face the losses
from a bank failure
regime
so
there were tortuous negotiations with
member states anxious to protect their
banking sectors some meps point out that
while banks will be forced to shoulder
losses in the first phase and to build a
55 billion euro restructuring or wine
line facility taxpayers may still not be
completely immune this cozy relationship
between bank owners and
their management and the national
governments is broken but
there are loopholes and these are have
been put there deliberately by the
member states there are two large
countries which were the most in favor
of these loopholes and that's france and
italy meps wanted to wind this file up
before the elections and they succeeded
just the question now for the new
european administration is will the new
rules be sufficient when if the next
banking crisis comes along